okay so the next talk is by Susanna Gurr
Zenda who's going to tell us about the
average case hardness so click for
regular resolution so yeah this talk is
a click as hard on average for regular
resolution and I'm Suzanne and there is
only from k th and now other things so
this is based on joint work with
Albert's Ilario
Massimo Jakob and Alexander okay so the
problem here is we're giving the graph
and we want to know whether it contains
a K click ok a clique of size K so for
example for the ones that haven't seen
this pocket this graph does it contain a
clique of size let's say 5 what would
you think yes yes right it looks like it
yes it does there you go click on size 5
ok so there's a contain a clique of size
6 no of course not right one answer yes
one answer no so no and this is a proof
that it doesn't well it's a 5 colorable
so it cannot contain a clique of size 6
ok so this is our problem and while it
is a like fundamental Camilla toriel
problem it's easy to determine if G
contains a K clique in time n to the K
by simply brute force algorithm and the
question is well is this optimal ok can
we do any better than this so what are
the lower bounds we know well assuming
ETH then there's no n to the little o of
K algorithm but can we prove any
unconditional lower bound right well in
particular it would show that P is not
equal to NP so what about bounded
computational model models what about
what algorithms actually do so this is a
corollary of our main result so
state-of-the-art algorithms require time
time and to the and
theta k to decide whether a random graph
contains a kick link and to the Omega K
okay and to analyze these algorithms
well we need to formalize well what is
the method of reasoning they use and if
you look at a graph that does not have a
cake-like and that you look at the trace
of the algorithm algorithm it has a
proof of the fact that there's no K
click and if we can lower bound the size
of such proofs well we lower bounding
the running time of the algorithm and
while this brings us to the topic which
is resolution so what is resolution well
I guess we've all seen this at the time
so we have them satisfy unsatisfiable
CNF formula and our goal is to certify
unsatisfiability using the resolution
rule right so we resolve over a variable
X plus C or X D or not X and we obtain a
Class C or D okay so here's an example
of a resolution proof and we say that if
the dog is a tree that this is tree like
resolution if we look any path from
contradiction to an axiom and there is
no variable which is resolved twice then
then we say that this is a regular proof
okay so so for example this proof is
regular if you check any any path so
here we're resolving over W we resolving
over X X and then over Y in the number Z
so in this path here there is no
variable being result twice and this is
true for all paths ok and the size of
the of the resolution proof is just the
number of nodes in the deck
all right we'll also be interested in
the branching program model and here
we're interested in branching programs
that solve the falsified class search
problem so what is this problem we're
giving them unsatisfiable formula an
assignment to the variables and their
goal is to find what cause is
unsatisfied by this assignments okay
so here's an example of such a branching
program so it starts by querying
variable zette and then if it gets one
it goes in one direction zero in the
other and suppose then queries X and
then it gets one and this assignment for
Zed being false and that being true and
X being true falsifies this clause okay
so this is a branching program solving
the falsified search problem and as you
might notice there's some similarity
between these two objects so so here's
our branching program and here's our
reservation proof so from a resolution
proof we can always obtain a branching
program solving the falsified search
problem and it's not very hard to see
well every time here you're resolving
over variable said and the branching
program can query Z and it will maintain
the property that at every node the the
assignments partial assignment it knows
so far
falsifies the corresponding clause in
the resolution tag okay so there is this
this correspondence and for a so for
branching program we can also define
tree like branching program which is
also known as a decision tree read one's
branching program it's similar to the
regular resolution so here no variable
is query twice and then the sourcing
path and the sizes again the number of
nodes in the duck and here in the
correspondence we have well a decision
tree solving the falsified Clause search
problem is equivalent to tree like
resolution also
reruns frenching programs or equivalents
to regular resolution but if you look at
just the general branching program then
what this can be exponentially stronger
than then resolution okay so in this
talk we'll be talking about regular
resolution and we'll be using this
correspondence between reruns branching
program and regular resolution so in
order to study the quick problem we need
to define an encoding here I'll give
like the simplest encoding for this talk
the result works for stronger encoding
so we need two types of clauses so first
we have variables XVI and they the
meaning is that vertex V is the I ate
quick member and then we have causes for
every I in K we have a clause that says
that there exists a ninth quick member
and then for every non edge in the graph
we have a cause saying that these two
vertices cannot both be clique members
because there's no edge between it
so from this encoding we have that well
this formula is satisfiable if and only
if G has a cake look I feel free to
threaten me and any points learn English
okay so what was known before well there
was an end to the Omega key lower bound
for tree like resolution also when K is
large a large polynomial then then we
have exponential lower bounds for
general resolution but there are many
reasons to care about small values okay
so that's what we're focusing on here
there are also results that holds for a
different encoding so for the binary
encoding which is an encoding it's
easier to prove lower bounds for then we
do have an end to the Omega K lower
bound for a general resolution and just
a few years a few days ago this other
results came which is also lower bound
invented Omega K for K res four so for
resolution over where yeah over log log
and DN apps okay okay so we would like
to prove this for general resolution so
we have this milestone in between for
regular resolution which is what we
obtain here okay and this is also an
interesting problem because the usual
proof complexity tools we have for
proving lower bounds they seem to fail
for this problem yes
so from binary to the unary encoding
there if you have this this bound for
general resolution you cannot obtain one
for unary not sure the other way around
I'm not sure what these authors show is
that if you could prove for the binary
encoding a log n ya resolution over log
and DNS then you would get something for
unary encoding but you will need
something stronger
yeah than what they have you know ready
for general resolution yeah yeah
these random restriction
okay so so yeah so for our inner
encoding these techniques don't don't
seem to work okay so in order to prove a
lower bound we need a hard graph
instance so here's the candidates it's a
complete K minus one part a graph so it
has many K minus one clicks but doesn't
have any K click and well it happens
that it this is hard for a tree like
resolution but for a regular resolution
it's easy so regular resolution can do
this and 2 to the K N squared we're
thinking of K small this is small and in
fact this is true for any K minus 1
color blue graph ok so let's try a
better hard instance so if we look at
editor any random graph so we have nine
vertices and we include every edge with
probability P then well the threshold
freaking for having a K clique is will P
about that and to the minus 2 over K
minus 1 and if we choose feet slightly
below then we already know that with
high probability there will be no K
clique so these are going to be our
heart instances so here's a slightly
more formal statement of our theme so
for K up to n to the 1/4 if we choose P
slightly less than the threshold so that
there's no K clique with high
probability any regular resolution
refutation of the clique formula has
length and to the Omega K just a pigeon
hope it's principle for average case
because a pizza it's pretty someone is
that inside the clique right so the way
I presented it that's true so this is
like a simple and quote-unquote anywhere
it is yeah and you can trivially get it
2 to the K lower bound so actually you
can you can add some clauses which
which gives some ordering on your clique
members so that if let's say vertex are
numbered from one through n so if vertex
one can only be a smaller clique number
than vertex 2 ok if you add those then
you cannot embed pigeonhole here it's
yeah average Cates so given the like a
random graph and well I guess it's an
expander right okay all right okay so
okay so this is a tight lower above
because there's there is an upper bound
of n to the okay which can be done even
in tree like resolution so tree like
resolution can do this brute-force
algorithm and what we prove is slightly
more general in the sense that even if
we have smaller dense densities we get
some lower bound and the lower bound
degrades with smaller density so if the
graph is sparser there's it's seems
easier to prove that there's no K clique
ok so now let's go to a proof overview
ok so what makes a graph a hard instance
right well a random graph we would guess
it's hard but what is it that makes it
hard so here are some ideas maybe it has
many like small clicks ok it doesn't
have any K clique but it has many small
cliques so maybe this is what makes it
hard well we know this cannot be because
I came - on protoid has many K minus 1
cliques and it's not hard so let's try
something else
well a good expansion right we all know
the grandeur graphs are good expanders
so maybe this gives hardness
when we try this but we couldn't get it
to work maybe it's not enough to tell me
have expansion so our third attempt is
that in some sense we have small clicks
there are many different ways we can
expand it okay and I'll get back to this
later we can make a right technical
definition okay
so here's a overview of the proof we
wish to define some community real
property which we'll call quick
denseness such that for any click dense
graph G we have a lower bound of n to
the K and then we show that with high
probability our editor the graph
satisfies this property okay so we'll
focus on my 1 and the definition of this
property so the proof technique will be
a bottleneck accounting algorithm in the
style of Hawkins so let's go over this
we have a regular resolution refutation
of this formula I can think of it as the
read once branching program and an
assignment to the to the variables
defines a path from from the roots to
some from the sink to some source which
at every point so at every point it the
cause president that point is falsified
by by the assignments right so we can
follow this path and here the idea is we
wish to define some sort of bottleneck
node for which we can prove two things
that every path
in a distribution which will define
traverses some bottleneck node and the
probability that alpha traverses some
fixed bottleneck note is small so this
is the general idea and bottleneck
accounting techniques okay so so then
what do we have we'd take a Union bounce
so we know that for any fixed bottleneck
sorry we know that the probability that
there exists about all that can be such
that all four traverses B is 1 but for
any fixed for any fixed B we know that
this probability is small so by a union
bound argument we get a bound of okay so
this is the idea of what we want to do
except we'll need a twist to it okay and
the twist is that we won't be able to
define a single bottleneck node but we
somehow needs two nodes so we'll define
the bottleneck pair and and the rest
will be exactly the same so we'll have
the same relation
so so our goal will so I'll define the
distribution of the paths now and define
what the bottleneck nodes are and then
our goal which I'm going to write here
will be to define a combinatorial
property such that the probability over
alpha that there exists a bottleneck
pair
be such that alpha
services a B so this is one and the
second property we want is that for any
fixed a B the probability that alpha
versus a B is less than n to the minus
so this will be our goal
in order to define oh wait forget to
that I can already define the
distribution on the paths okay it's a
very natural distribution so we will
start at the source and at any point we
when we query your variable we'll do the
following if there is no way that this
path will falsify such an axiom so so
this axiom is saying that there that
there is some ayat clique member so when
will there not be no way that this will
falsify well if it already identified a
nice quick member then there's no way
it's going to falsify there are also
other cases for example if it's queried
some some XVI before some xui before and
it forgot it since this is regular
resolution it cannot query it again it
can only create once on every path so
then it will never be able to falsify
this axiom in order to falsify this it
needs to remember that all the XVI's are
0 so and if there is no way alpha will
falsify xvi then we can safely answer 0
and if we set x VI equals 1 and this
falsify some edge axiom so this means
that i already identified some clique
member and now this is not a neighbor of
a crick member i identified so i should
not say that it is a quick member else i
will immediately get a contradiction so
in this case i also answer 0 so i'm
somehow forced to answer 0 in this case
and otherwise if we're not in any of
these two cases then I'll just throw a
coin and with probably probability n to
the minus 1/2 I'll answer one otherwise
I'll answer 0 so this is this will be
the distribution on on our paths
and now in order to define what a
bottleneck pair is I'll need the
following definition so the common
neighborhood of a set of vertices so
this is these this is the neighbor these
are the neighbors of this vertex and
these are the neighbors of the blue
vertex so if I look at this set at this
at are the common neighbors will be just
intersection of the neighborhoods okay
we can think of well if R is a clique
then the common neighbors of our are the
possible extensions of our farming a
clique okay what are ways I can extend
our and still have a clique okay now one
more definition so if I if I have a set
W of vertices and I will often be
interested in how many ways can I extend
this clique are inside W okay so suppose
that we have many common neighbors of
are inside W then we say well W extends
are in many ways this is clear okay so
now we can we can define what our
bottleneck pairs are yes
extend you men by one by one vertex
extend by one vertex yes exactly
so I'll define the bottleneck pairs and
at the same time I'll prove point one
okay so we have so given a a path alpha
from our distribution
we can make the following observations
well alpha will falsify some of these
wide axioms so why is this well we're
never falsifying an edge axiom so the
short axioms are never falsified
so when it ends it will it will have to
be falsifying some of the membership
axioms okay now suppose that for we fix
J suppose alpha is falsifying this X V J
then we know that well alpha must query
all the X V J's for all vertices V in in
a vertex I set and they must set all of
these to 0 that's the only way you can
falsify this class now ok and now one
more observation is that alpha so any
path in our distribution identifies at
most K clique members and why is this
the case
well if
right so alpha densifies at most K
clique members and this is the case
because if I ever identified a quick
member on some is position I will never
answer one for for I again okay so now
what we can do is so consider a path
alpha we can split this path
into t segments
it was split it into T segments such
that in any of these segments here all
those identifying less than K over T
clique members
so for every path there exists such w0w
out of the WT that splits it in this way
and you can think of T as a small
constant T equals five or something okay
now since we know that all these
variables have to be queried and set to
zero and this is regular resolution so
it only does this once on any path this
also defines a partition of my vertices
in V according to when were they set to
zero in between which of these so this
will define some partition so this will
be W 1 so V
okay and now I will say that WI minus 1
WI but this is a bottleneck pair is a
bottom if the following holds so if this
WI so the vertices that were set to 0
between WI minus 1 WI if this extends
all small quicks
in many ways
this somehow represents that progress
has been made here so this path has to
set all of the to zero in the JH block
and and this represents that Oh between
these two a lot of progress was made in
general we could think that oh if WI is
large then a lot of progress is made if
I if I was a between these two verses I
said many things to zero but this is not
enough because maybe there was these
were all the non neighbors of one vertex
I already identified in my clique so it
was really easy to it did not require
any coin flipping so in this sense the
idea is that it will require a large
amount of coin flipping
why should we think that there is such
an i right
so we want a combinatorial property that
guarantees that there exists such an i
exactly so so what will this come in at
aerial property me yes alright so the
first part of the click dense definition
is that we want some common internal
property but such that there will always
be such an i and this is the the formal
definition so far for all small clicks
let's see a size at most k over twenty
that common neighborhood of our is large
this will be the community really that
will guarantee that there exists an i
and because this will imply that if i
partition V then there will be such an
eye for any partition of V into T parts
there will be such an eye such that I
lose only a T here in both what large
means and the size of the small cliques
it's a very simple argument see me no no
it's it's very simple I mean it's you
can prove it by contradiction there's no
I then you look at the R such that this
is not true you put them together and
you'll get another such that this is not
true it's very simple okay so it's okay
so this will guarantee our point number
one
now we need a second part of the
definition which will guarantee the
point number two
so this is what we we want to guarantee
and now we'll have two cases okay so in
one case on so I will call these bottle
vac notes a and B
so suppose a B is a bottleneck node in
in one case we have that at the verdicts
a we have already identified many clique
members so at least epsilon K clique
members number one now we wanted to
property that it will give us number two
no no I'm going to try to lead you to
understand why we need this property
okay okay so okay so first there's an
easy case which is so if a already
identifies many quick members and why is
this easy well the partial X assignment
at a has these epsilon K variables which
are set to 1 and we know that one ones
are always the result of a coin flip so
then we we already automatically get
that that the probability that alpha
passes through a not even through B but
only through a is already and to the
minus K so this is an easy case
okay so now what happens if a identifies
less than epsilon K clique members and
okay so let are a be the set of vertices
set to one at a so the clique members a
identifies and and let W be the set of
vertices that are set to 0 between a and
B we know that each non for 0 has
probability 1 minus n to the minus 1/2
so suppose we have like many non for
cereals okay so something a lot larger
than and to the haha then we would get
that the probability that offer Traverse
is a B well it has to set all of W to 0
from A to B so then we would get an
exponentially small bounce and then we
would be fine and while there's seems to
be some hope that something like this
could be true because we we know that
our a is small and W extends all small
cliques and many ways so if if it is a
possible extension of our a it will not
be a forced choice it will not falsify
any edge axiom so then we have hope that
we we could get such a so many coin
flips so why is this not enough well
before querying the vertices in W maybe
our path identified more more click
members so let our alpha be the set of
vertices between a and B that were
identified as click members okay so if
we knew that these would still leave
enough non forced zeros then we would be
fine
you would have some probability which is
exponentially small but if this does not
happen then let's say that this our
alpha is probably not problematic for
this w because it's it's somehow rules
out almost all the possible
extensions of this click inside W and
the property we want must guarantee that
the probability that we choose an RL for
that is problematic for W is small so
this is this is the what we need to
finish the proof some property that I
will guarantee is this
so this is the property that we define
so so first what we said was to
guarantee one was that we can extend any
K over 20 clique in many ways and now
for two what we need is that for any set
W that can extend k over a hundred
clicks in many ways okay so it's the
ideas it's it looks somehow like what a
random W would look like if you chose it
so it it can extend small cliques in
many ways then it can also extend almost
any K over ten clique in many ways okay
so now I'm going to choose Creek which
is a lot larger than what my guarantee
gives me and I still want that for
almost all of these I can extend it in
many ways and here will be a more formal
statement and a attempt of a proof by
picked of a definition by picture so
this would be so for any set W that
satisfies the top that extends any K
over 100 clique in many ways then there
exists a small set s such that any
keratin clique that cannot be extended
into W in many ways must intersect s in
many vertices so suppose this is a W and
for all small arts there are many ways I
can extend it into W and now we take a
much larger or a prime and now maybe
this shrunk more than what would be
expected
maybe it's very small yes
yes yes I can let me finish this and
I'll tell you yes okay so suppose now I
have like an hour prime which has a
small number of possible extensions
inside W so this means that it
intersects they said as a lot so for for
every W there must exist a set s such
that any large or a prime that has small
number of possible extensions in W must
intersect s a lot so this will restrict
the number of problematic ours or
Prime's I can have because they any R
prime that's problematic must intersect
eyes a lot so this is the cognitive
property that will give us number two
and this was something we could not just
get out of expansion so right okay so
yes your question so why why isn't it's
not true for for K minus one part I
graphs right so let's see
yes so I think like the like like with
the naive statement of the time the
second property like it almost seems
like it could be true for K minus one
color blue graph but like I think that
this is actually saying something
stronger right you're you're not only
saying that you can also extend almost
any K over ten click here you're also
saying it like the errors are somehow
like localized that make sense yes yes
it is that the set this contains K minus
K over 100 colors any K over and let me
try to get picture so what happens for
the K minus one for tight graph is that
we we are looking for K member K clique
members and the K minus one for tight
graph so actually the picture looks like
so this is would be like I equals 1 up
to y equals K and these are my variables
so this would be like the rolls are like
for V so this is like V equals 1 up to V
equals n so this is my variable X 1 1 X
X V I so X 1 1 okay and if it's if it's
K partite what if what I'm what do we
mean is that here split this since you
like K minus its came in this one for
its height I'll split this into K minus
1 blocks and the edges that our presents
are only between these blocks so since
we don't care inside here we can think
of it like this so these edges are
present
[Music]
but not edges inside here okay so okay
so now what happens is that there let's
see
so so I can have a reset
and that's all to disallow yes
firstly we don't need to extend the
Kaitlyn is this the common neighborhood
of any guys that don't necessarily need
to be Oakley someone cheating example is
suppose you have a click on on all the
other parts of the partition and now
look at just one part and Kelly that
half extends like all the clicks on the
other guys in many different ways second
app as soon as I pick up any vertex in
that second half of course now I can no
longer extend it with a click in the
first half of this port but the phone if
you extend the cream - no I think it I
think it translates to this setting up
at the voice is like that if I just look
at one part of my cake what I'd rather
then any vertex in the first half of
that part roots out that I could and
expand it click further with any vertex
from the second half of that part and
that is not a small set that's like a
very low such that like half of that one
and I think that's sort of that's the
whole point so that means that as soon
as I like I take that for tight I chop
it up into two parts supports then any
vertex from the first support as soon as
I get that I can take anything from the
Sephardim support and so that is a set s
that sort of makes things crush and it's
not the small sets that is like a huge
set so that's
it does although I will need to go
offline to guard the details okay so I
can get back to you later
okay right so now some conclusions so
well we proved them n to the K average
case they were bound for regular
resolution and then holds for well it's
a week but a non-trivial proof system
and while some open problems would be
well can we we prove this for a -
reading random graph can we prove this
hardness for an explicit graph
what about Ramsey graphs so yeah so we
have a go suppose we have a graph that
has no clique of size log N and no
independent set of size log and can we
show that for those graphs we need enter
the login can we extend this to general
resolution and yeah and beyond general
resolution
let's take questions for Leung sits up
you'll uh pop axioms not xdi or ma:index
Mui that's a mapping from vertices to
plate numbers isn't objective but you're
yes yes that's the place yes exactly
number one yes he said that like a like
an area random graph satisfies this
property or what that is a P right so
you if you're a bit below the threshold
it's fine so you can go you can go quite
a bit below I guess I can tell you it's
so that the threshold was P was n to the
minus two over K minus one so then I
mean if you put a parameter ADA here and
you choose like ADA greater than one
we're below the threshold so I think
what we do is ADA up to think it's
square root K or something some some
thing that depends on K
the questions there were any connection
to privately well I guess planted click
when and then so as you talk about
plants a click and you look at the proof
complexity what you're doing it's
actually you're just proving that are
shining a train they've got the song
containing K click so I guess it's yeah
very similar
well it's thanks to something
[Applause]